this is the beginning of times the
goddess cysts have protected us but one
day came a mysterious cube from outer
space
a mysterious cube with evil intense and
grey power suddenly from a single blow
he transformed the world he trapped all
goddesses and thick walls of ice cubes
my god
without the goddesses to protect the
earth the evil came from outer space
proceeded with his plan he turned
everything and everyone into cubes all
hope was lost as he can see with these
two gentlemen's faces there's no hope in
them but one day Alex decided he had
enough of Ali's crap before he was like
yeah whatever
but one day determined to save the
goddesses he build a jet pack and flew
to their rescue
how could he build anything he doesn't
even have thumps my [ __ ] kitty there
Oh kitty mode got it up
welcome to uncraft me this game is on
green light so I figured we should play
it it's game got greenlit so I figured
we should play all right let's go my god
so this is a mixture of paint and
minecraft yeah alright that's pretty
cool it's pretty straightforward girl
let's be honest we're all just playing
this for the boobs
give me the boobs my god what is that a
leg oh my god so the chick fight you get
to see more skin or whatever my god
it's like hey listen I made this shitty
game but listen I don't know how to make
it better you know what let's add boobs
oh there they are this is genius really
I can't I can't say anything bad about
it I did it
give me them titties yeah yeah I feel
bad watching this I mean I have a
girlfriend it's not if not me it's the
gay might sway man those nips must be
gigantic holy [ __ ] I'm just saying yay
we get to look at that this is a picture
do they know that are they aware that
it's just a picture a guide it gets
harder
I flew inside the lava but no one gives
a [ __ ] examine a quest for some titties
I'm a quite good night this is just like
real life
always a quest for some good old saggy
titties not even hard man Jesus give me
some challenge I want to work for them
titties though they are side boob now
that's a bunch are now bad explode the
[ __ ] am I supposed to do about these
there we go nice wonderful legs oh wow I
mistook her boobs for ass what the [ __ ]
best game ever attend attend let's be
honest all right we have say race
whatever the [ __ ] that is
checkpoint what do I get what is that is
that a nice own titty that's that's a
real question about this game I think
that it's oh god I got distracted son of
a [ __ ] oh my god I just noted there's a
game in this game I just saw boobs some
titties and ass boobs and titties good
job kids is it me or does it cannon
looks like a Christmas tree
just want to mention that not today okay
maybe today not today
okay okay oh god I'm gonna get up yeah
give it that side boob no no it's side
boob oh god oh god oh god yeah
ah oh god [ __ ] whatever got I must be
like double [ __ ] Zetas I don't know
Jesus this is probably like I played a
lot of great games tonight I know I say
a lot that oh my god it has to be the
best game ever but this really has to be
the best game ever
I mean why do you not stop what the [ __ ]
I have an idea why don't you just move
around Nick maybe they don't stop or
some [ __ ] okay hurry [ __ ]
I just have to be Co quack I could just
have to be quick I mean whatever same
thing go Oh God oh forget a little
upskirt baby why do I have wide fair
hair why am I such a [ __ ] pervert
why are you still watching this video Oh
God all these questions why will I soon
but no answers they will come and since
we're car Wow
now it's started all right yes No ah
give my solid gameplay great graphics
and a lot of night knotch
this is really what notch wanted to make
when he made Minecraft
it just couldn't find the right pictures
to put in the background really this
game just it's probably gonna be the new
Minecraft let's be honest here there it
has any game I never seen so oh my god
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] okay we gotta hurry
okay okay okay oh god I'm literally
inside the lava I'm so good so good I
don't know why I'm but I'm enjoying this
game and it's not only for the boobs I
promise oh nice what is that an ass or a
boob I can never tell I can never tell
why am I so bad at this I feel like such
a pervert but the game the game it's not
me I beat the game Wow
all right so this is uncraft me too
because they made the second one before
they finish the first one years later
Cuba Tron the integral addict evil was
still looking for wells to Cuba fie that
[ __ ] when he found an inhabited solar
system bah blah blah blah blah narrower
than boobs in church and then alex is
like I love tits alright let's go save
Lauren oh my god why they think they
really showed significant improvement
from the first game I am really
impressed by Wow oh they have panty shot
now great this is gonna come out on
Steam who the [ __ ] voted for this son
steam
I guess cuz like oh I saw a lot of other
big youtubers play this before but it
still doesn't explain it
okay you know what that explained it
perfectly for me a underboob Oh God they
really stepped up the difficult they
know since the game looks identical as
the second first one what that what they
didn't change [ __ ] oh whoa okay here's
new that was new my up oh [ __ ] I can't
go inside the fan Wow
thanks bro does he make noises now
didn't make noises before there we go
just get it [ __ ] don't [ __ ] this watch
anime porn it's safer trust me right in
the eye that's offensive
Wow okay I'm skipping these give me some
of that yeah love it I just soiled my
pants guess this game is so hard oh wow
hello okay let's shoot that face right
in the mouth really in the mouth you
know what okay golden stuff ever this
looks a little Super Mario in Spain oh
my god did he add that I don't think
that wasn't the first game come on ooh
give me some of that badge this game is
an objective objectifying rabbit no it
just shows that boys are [ __ ]
perverts
oh this part it's pretty difficult
ah Sh ah oh oh there we go
good job Pierce oh God
Oh got down here there we go that's what
I'm talking about girl Jesus yeah I know
it should call it boob point let's be
honest that's what it is yeah give me
something on Terra's Oh shoulder Wow no
more rockets oh god oh god Jess give me
some titties don't quote me on that I
just want the checkpoint that's all I
promise okay hurry up okay okay
did it show me some legs whoa
right in the cheek wonderful my god
thumbnail we finished the game I wonder
how long they thought about that story
cuz it's [ __ ] good there we go
the kidding mode I I don't know why I
I guess they I don't I I can't explain
this show me that kidding come on show
me some of that oh my god that fur oh my
god so hot oh my god okay all guy died I
just so good I just want to take a brush
and brush I'll get me some more
oh it's more fair oh it's a nose no it's
so hot what else we got
oh the blue stuff what else did we get
oh we get to scene I I'm gonna why what
else I'm gonna see him back kidding oh
my god it was ice what else do we get I
can't handle a oh my god oh that's so
kitsch wow so good who's next I can't
pick that are also good free yeah it's
Victoria I can keep tabbing if I change
my mind I can easily select if I want to
see some all right now that's way better
you know what this is way better
it's so much hotter I don't know about
oh God oh so ugly this is way better
alright give me some more of that [ __ ]
I don't know are they catering to keep
kittens playing this game I I don't
understand why this exists Eve like this
is even more puzzling than the first
part the first part I can grab my head
around or in a 12 year olds I get it but
this is just weird man give me some of
that Posay oh yeah baby
sweet sweet [ __ ] sweetheart furry and
hairy [ __ ] what else we got nothing
oh okay that's that's so cute that's
adorable
now you know why I changed my mind okay
all right that was uncracked me
why is this green late why does this
exist this game just raised a lot of
questions I don't know but to be honest
I don't give a [ __ ] so that was that let
me like um you're watching Russ and I'll
see you tomorrow but new episode love
you buzz let me like if you enjoy hairy
[ __ ] and I'll see you tomorrow